it's been another week and it's time for
a
covid weekly update tuesday seem to be a
good day for these because it allows
sort of the weekend data to be smoothed
out sometimes on the weekends there's
these
dumps of data sometimes on the weekends
data and reporting slow down on vaccines
or cases or whatever
so looking at it tuesday wednesday seems
to make sense and we're going to look
again at cases to begin with but
increasingly
you know as more and more people get
vaccinated uh and
getting the virus for the vaccinated
means something much less serious than
it used to for unvaccinated people
cases may become less an important
indicator than hospitalizations
and of course deaths as our more
important measures but
let's start where we always do with
cases cases in the united states
peaked on january 11th at the incredible
and nearly unbelievable number of 255
000 cases per day
since that peak cases have declined
about 78 percent
to 55 000 cases per day now 55 000 cases
per day is still outrageous and when we
got
up to 55 000 cases per day we were
completely horrified and rightly so
many never imagined we'd ever get to 55
000 cases a day remember some people
told us
15 cases will soon be zero but right now
55 000 cases a day means we're down 78
percent in about two months so that's
the right direction
if we saw another 78 percent decline
over the next two months we'd be at
about 12 000 cases in mid-may now it's
unclear whether that's going to happen
the decline has already slowed down
but at the same time if vaccination
continues to accelerate
maybe the decline will accelerate as
well we just don't know right now
in terms of people going into the
hospital each day
with the virus we peaked right around
january 9th
when 16 000 people were being
hospitalized
each day with the virus in the united
states
we are now at 4 500 people being
hospitalized
each day with the virus that's a decline
of 73 percent
and then in terms of the total number of
people in the hospital with covid right
now
that peak was also on january 10th when
we had 124 000 people in the hospital
that number is down 75 percent to
30 000 people remaining in the hospital
with covid
in the united states and then deaths
deaths peaked around the end of january
at more than a 9 11's worth of deaths
every day we were seeing about 3 400
deaths a day at the end of january
deaths are now down to an average of
1282
which is still horrifying but it's a
decline of 63
it's tough to be happy about 1282 people
dying a day of this virus
and yet we recognize that being down 63
percent to 1282
is better than a continued spike to 1282
in the sense that the direction we're
going in is the right one
and remember that deaths trail cases
by a few weeks they're a lagging
indicator
so we expect that deaths would continue
down
similar to cases but again at a certain
point
as more people get vaccinated and people
start doing more things
you may see cases level out because
people will be transmitting the virus
but because so many people will be
vaccinated they're not going to be
seriously ill
that may happen we're not there yet but
we may be going in that direction now
lastly vaccination
vaccination we want to see going up of
most of these indicators indicators
we want to see go down vaccinations you
want to see go up
and we are now averaging 2.4 million
vaccine doses injected per day
over the last week that is a number that
continues to go
up last week we were at 2.1 million a
day
now we're at 2.4 million a day and we
have roughly
38 million fully vaccinated americans
and another 32 million partially
vaccinated that means about
70 million americans are fully or
partially vaccinated
these are increasingly good numbers to
see
now one last thing these are all u.s
numbers
what is happening globally with the
virus is the virus
growing or diminishing globally and the
answer is it sort of depends
there are parts of the world seeing
spikes look at brazil
brazil has been one of the worst places
in the world for covet handling thanks
to
bolsonaro it actually is now peaking
brazil is now at the highest of its
four or five peaks with more active
cases today
than at any point during the pandemic in
brazil there are some european countries
starting to spike vaccine rollout has
not been great in many parts of europe
and indeed globally overall
cases are going up while they are down
almost 80 percent in the u.s
cases are going up globally cases
globally bottomed out
at around 360 000 a day uh
not long ago a few weeks ago they are
now back up to 430
000 global cases a day fortunately
deaths continue to decline partially
because
many countries are getting better at
treating people who get seriously ill
partially because the world is starting
to vaccinate uh the most
at-risk individuals but deaths peaked
around
14 000 a day in early february there are
now 8 500 people a day
globally dying of coronavirus so the
takeaways are
there's a ton of work to be done numbers
are improving
in countries that have done more
vaccination but there are still parts of
the world
seeing more cases there are still parts
of the world that aren't likely to get
any significant number of vaccines for a
long time
all we can do is go by the guidelines
that our
respective health authorities are giving
us in the us it's the cdc
cdc urging caution but opening up
some safe activities for vaccinated
people we will give it another week
and then see where things are today's
episode is sponsored by
bluechew a unique online service
delivering the same
active ingredients as viagra and cialis
in a chewable form and at a fraction of
the cost
and they're giving my audience an entire
month's supply for
free take a short quiz on the bluechew
website a licensed doctor approves your
prescription
and the medication goes right to your
home in a discreet package no driving to
the doctor's office
having a possibly awkward conversation
waiting in line at the pharmacy
bluechu replaces the entire process with
a few
clicks and way less expensive and all of
bluechews tablets are made
in the united states so if you think you
could benefit from an extra boost of
confidence
go to bluechew.com the link is under
this video and they'll give you an
entire month's supply for free when you
use promo code pacman
just pay five dollars for shipping